washington-dc turns two kinds of red
white and blue when the president of
France comes to town
Donald Trump is hosting his first state
visit pulling out all the stops for his
French counterpart their relationship
has been called everything from a
bromance to a marriage of convenience
but no matter which way you look at it
French president Emmanuel macron and US
president Donald Trump seem like an
unlikely pair one is a young globalist
the other a 71 year old with nationalist
instincts so how did the two form such a
close personal relationship some experts
say it comes down to their common
backgrounds in business and as outsiders
so it's paradoxical that they get along
so well given how different they are on
the surface but at the same time they
they are both self-made political men
you know that come from outside the
establishment that were elected when
nobody expected that and you know they
they really share this this experience
but how did the French feel about having
a president who has been called the
Trump whisperer these DC locals want to
see them work together I think it's a
better interest for him for the US and
for everybody to to get something out of
it even if you have to bend over a
little bit let president Trump know that
France is gonna be a huge partner with
the US and Europe in general and I think
president McComb wants to do that what
else do they expect to see from Trump
during the two leaders rendezvous in DC
I will try probably to get macron to war
this way and micron is not easy to to
handle so we'll see if we get fire work
or if we get another cherry blossom
macron we'll have to wait and see
whether his charm offensive can reap
rewards